so you came in here with the proposal
the Hoffman desk toughness to to
basically show the back story including
you know all of our work product I
stopped you yeah this is part of work
product right exactly so the thing in
restarting so the thinking is that you
know a lot of Kaufman's movies are kind
of write themselves a particular
adaptation being the most obvious
example of a typical character named
Charlie Kaufman who we realized his
writing within yourself or Washington
versus sort of infinite loop it happens
and a lot of you know my first impulse
was running a pitch was to sort of be
like here I am writing a visual block
and immediately realize this was a
mistake to do for an article because
everybody does this it's like the Scott
put on skype as a little bit that's the
first thing that comes to people's minds
it's the obvious to do but that
dimension and theme strikes me is
important and maybe one way of doing it
without hitting people over the head
with it quite so much would be just to
do it honestly instead of do it give it
go pee so the exam although this is
intellectually appealing is obviously
consistent with the theme I have to ask
even want to watch this maybe not um but
you know it that's another good thing
about it being online is both in the
magazine is they don't can watch it if
you're interested and if you're not you
don't but it's not the text of the story
exactly but don't be watching it'll be a
series of you know four minute video
here and and walk a lot of blog and yeah
hosting and Jason's rough draft right
email exchange here another video here
to warm up plenty of what is the point
may we stand back was the one
it's a point that it were so full of
ourselves that we were up the world so
you have regard every stage of the
process not to say oh no i'll tell you
what i think and but i definitely look
at different points out of the desperate
for me i think it is there is a lot of
distrust of art industry we go into the
we interview people and you wear this
black box and return stuff you to
content people think there is a part of
this going on there and that we are
taking that we take I mean not all of us
but basically so that that's one reason
I think that as your wire we talked
about about the transparencies we've
increasing trust between consumers and
the product and showing the making of it
and they're about deepening that
relationship I think that would all
right i like that i just had an
instructional institutional trust factor
dude everything else well the other
argument is that it happens to dovetail
quite nicely with this story which is
you know we would be watching this
content create itself there are thematic
resonances which make it particularly
work for the story i think you could
make it the first argument for any story
but it also just happens to be
particular residence a little bit of
them have them media going in that in
that respect answer you know the you
know going through the story you know
the journalistic narrative and court in
search of the actual narrative this is
the story about the story is you know it
is but anybody but it done a multimedia
web but in a non artificial way in a way
that it happens with every story the big
dick holes in the big risk is that we're
doing it on a daily basis we're showing
you need to give camera something about
so then the convenient sort of dovetail
I discovered on Thursday night when we
were talking about this was the kind of
work that I've been doing externally out
my blog on SPD and kind of pulling back
the curtain of showing how design effort
showing how stories actually make it
from writes letter into this meeting
into an edit that you guys were gone
that ends up being designed photographed
and showing all the steps that end up
turning into magazine pages like my
video you sent around a bit bad one
story gaining we designed and redesigned
it up you know modern times yeah and
that was like one component of it but
like I really pulling back the curtain
and showing all the nuts and bolts and
all the details of it but on a daily
basis on the blog we could tell the
story of how wire works a little bit we
can we could reveal Jason's processes
show how all the kind of intermingling
so blogging in real time starting now or
do file put everything out after so for
my purposes I would like to ask
permission to start showing stuff now
that I have a dedicated log on SPD where
I would be showing the wired process I
think I know that we have an empire that
when you're doing that the design
community obviously design communities
Anderson that's working my name
we're talking about for the readers we
have to come to some sort of point of
all of this yeah these are not magazine
people the magazine people will
inherently be interested in the
Protestant I said I mean I think going
back to yes or no I mean I think that I
think that you're right we can't throw
and the big question is when do we put
stuff up you put it up immediately how
much do we put stuff up you put of every
male 2 what point people can I like I
don't give a you know um but I
think you know if you hit the right
balance it's like I mean I'm not I
wouldn't ever imply that any of us are
Charlie Kaufman but you know that people
are interested to see I think there's an
interest to see how these things
actually do it when college this is
already being Charlie Kaufman is a story
that's posted and then below that is
inside the making the entire wires
making upbeat Charlie copper right and
I'm trying to send you things really
sort of touching which are talking with
you that's that's exactly right that
just inside this behind scene that's
right of which isn't very kinda we're
doing this is part of this but that's
all I'm offering I don't think we're
everything more than than the emails the
meanings the the blogging and the
hallway conversations that and the
marked up copy that led to the story and
yes our attention to it shows that I
think the reason it's consistent with
the cosmic stuff is you know the coffin
stuff makes you very rarely constructive
nature of what you're watching but
somehow he ties it all together makes
another nail he makes it part right and
then we're not gonna make it crew behind
seat yeah that's all do that doesn't
feel like enough to do you don't think
you can edit this into a narrative I
should know I'm hoping that this that's
what we can
although our kids it's not i mean i
think that when you start when you start
editing it into a narrative that's when
it becomes the magazine piece that it's
like Here I am but you've gotta edit
this so how do you add it into anything
but a narrative I mean it's a natural
there's a chronology that Messiah
doesn't have to build into some great
drama or a moment in chennai college so
i think the first thing to do would be
to get my car initial emails about this
conversation up there and the niccola
pitch maybe pick up their tips fine yeah
i'll just share everything asks
everything i've written such as soon as
he's right cool that's great gmail
address redacted yes all right thank you
guys thank you